because we just went McConaughey I mean
how big
[Laughter]
hi guys it's Greg Alva here with the
lovely and talented and extremely buff
charming oh my god everything okay you
managed arms are massive I'll get on
with silly training that we went through
yeah yeah there's a buffest when I
collide but you could kick Campion at
anything
they're like right in the middle between
buff and have it worked out Alice could
outrun you but yeah I could beat him in
an arm wrestling crash that is correct
if you haven't caught on East from
Collider videos Collider TV talkies the
host of he just had a Schmo now match
recently and he has to just shoot the
show on YouTube the hi and John Humphrey
did episode we I love that I believe it
got 500,000 views here we're going
eight-minute most viewed video more if
you more than most SNL go check it out
hey mokuba I've got a little bit of a
rough night
yeah transition rough night a stricted
restricted kids into whoo
that's in the business what you called a
segue a segue well I'm working on my
transitions and making it not so all if
you saw the first trailer for I didn't
yeah so did I have you done the second
one rush for joke
I love those okay before we go we got to
do human friends but yeah what is a
human friend Pete it's a better way I
think it's like the movie human
centipede where they're sewn together ah
but it's with friends so special you've
been dreaming about the gentleman it's
the first day of freshman year we're
going to be ones that don't I don't know
I was kind of hoping that we can make it
an irony this until right yeah I don't
think so baby girl
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
like Chris Hemsworth yeah like a digger
accident or totally [ __ ] eclectic
David with guy in Australia the cooked
his girlfriend and I - yeah I probably
have HPV news whatever real obviously I
don't have HPV if you have sex ought to
be in 1991 than you do I'll tell ya
there's I don't say what there is
nothing like a great girl brought you
come absolutely like me
awesome minutes movie look look so Larry
yeah yeah another percent the first year
that I was still like at a bit skeptical
mama to this trailer they let the scenes
play out a little warm yet watching the
way all of them are they're also fine
throws her hands is a little bit funnier
yeah they're the first time like typical
advice is funny at all this one okay I'm
either throwing her in an ensemble movie
where she isn't scarlet Widow or black
with yeah yeah she's not an action hero
yeah she's a normal girl what I love
about movies like this like bridesmaids
like whatever is they they don't pull
any punches the reason I didn't love the
first trailer of this I like this one
more it's like what you said it's
expanded it's a lot of fun but also in
the first time I watched the trailer was
like wait a second this is weekend at
Bernie's equation at burn it's really
fun turn right so I didn't see it coming
and I'm like listen if you kill a
stripper just call the cops it's like it
happened what are you gonna do they have
its man so does you kill driver
edit that out but if you happen to call
the cops just like gonna hide the body
no like shinobi like okay so we're
playing the game and I actually jumped
on him and I'm like he hit his head and
like [ __ ] happens you probably won't
like it I hope that's like a man flutter
which is an accidental murder
I don't know the law what I'm saying is
that if you're out of a [ __ ] this is
going the wrong way
excuse my language we got to edit that
out right it's too late this trailer so
are yeah yeah yeah this videos are
striking out all right might as well say
[ __ ] balls cut the whole video does not
matter anymore
yes can with many strippers as possible
while put it out fixers out don't kill
surfers guys invite them in your home
treat them lovely I'm jacked into money
LLL strangle it just don't do it now
this one this is I think this will be
what bridesmaids was yeah I think it has
a very bright bridemaid tone has the
Stars had the star quality of it all and
a lot of those girls like obviously
Jillian Belk crushes it in 22 Geoffrey
she's amazing and workaholics so the
girl from broad city of the she's
fantastic
zoe kravitz joey Cravath did you see a
lot yeah yeah oh my god she was great in
that show I know Vince I raided that
show and and Kate McKenna doing I'll
show you a cadet really authentic I know
if I didn't see interviews of Kate
McKinnon I would have seen that and be
like oh is she really Australian she's
doing her actual accident yeah it's like
Don Cheadle in the Ocean's eleven oh
yeah yeah actually that that people make
the the stripper cuz I remember when I
saw it first trailer see when I was a
little thrown off by a stripper dying I
this is what every we're gonna remember
this guy's got almost outta hand over
the circuit bag rule number one with a
stripper knife it called a blink all the
poi rule number two call the cop and
I'll try and either stripper body
there's always a trail they're gonna
know the stripper went there laughs yeah
it's all your clerical error lot do it
that phone yes I think what makes this
trailer it better was the darker tone
was kind of set up already before the
killing happened like it is funny but
you can feel kind of a dark debauchery
night
yeah you know I've been doing cocaine I
love seeing this because there's so many
girls I know that they lift a party like
this doesn't mean like I'm always
partying with it what I just know it
when girls go out they like to have a
good time just like the dudes in the
hangover absolutely yeah how much fun is
it to see when you're walking into a
club see a girl leaving the club being
escorted out with a broken heel like
that the bet is something oh and to do
from an era Roy Roy Roy Hudd and you saw
Phil Dunphy four-mile dummy yeah good
yeah good celeb came again excited for
this I think this is going to be a
really funny movie agreed yeah I think
it'd be really fun great oh one thing
I'll say is like at this point I feel
like it's more than just a female
version of The Hangover yeah you know if
you'll get a lot more than that all
right women keep up the work stays funny
hey if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell to hear about
strippers being killed and follow us on
our new patreon a lot of [ __ ] going on
there
and we might get an interview with
makuta for a patreon and of course the
dr. Kilgus show on YouTube we're I'm
putting where you're going to click yeah
maybe
or you keep doing that whatever and it
keeps you under table I do its outro and
of course Collider videos Collider TV
sake is the ho stuff he was just on the
show down just last week his episode
aired go follow him online oh my gosh
everything mokuba I think about Dan
night he has a hot fiancee follow him on
Instagram to see what she looks like
that's why I do it goodbye